this is Reinhart Lawrence doing what he
loves best collecting sorting cataloging
he helped build up the international
archive for jazz and popular music in
Eisen ah hello my name is Fran Hut
Lawrence welcome in the wonderful town
of asana this place is one of my
lovelies
lovelyz places here I left my heart for
more than 40 years in mid of records
from jazz rock and pop music but Asenath
has another Tom's places
please follow me Reinhard Lawrence's
first recommendation is in the old town
asana works to preserve its cultural
heritage which includes a 600 year old
musical tradition this is my first
favorite place in eyes enough and it's a
connection to this person johann
sebastian bach one of the greatest
composers and one of the first jazz
musicians
the BA house with its 250 original
exhibits is the world's largest
exhibition dedicated to the composer's
life and work
when you grow up in Eisenach and live
here then it's this house the middle of
your life every time when I can I come
back to this house to feel the sound and
the music of Johann Sebastian Bach and
find here power and feeling for my life
every our music is performed live in the
back house on historical instruments we
continue to the pratik acacia a church
builds in honor of Saint Elizabeth it's
now a museum as enough is not only a
town of music costs you can find also
churches and religion this is my second
favorite place Supriya search a place
for the holy Elisabeth you can find
inside a wonderful exhibition with
sculptures and figures from the middle
age please follow me to look
although religious services are no
longer held in the church visitors are
still often filled with a sense of
reverence
please look with me into these faces and
into the figures you can find in it more
than 400 years of peace and silence isin
acts most famous landmark Varberg castle
provided reshot vogner inspiration for
his opera Tannhauser
eysan ox collection of vogner
memorabilia is second only to the
collection in by Hoyt housed in a villa
once occupied by poet foots whiter it's
called the whiter Varna Museum
for music lovers like Reinhard Lawrence
these are real treasures more than
20,000 original scores letters writings
figures the life and work of Richard
Wagner illuminated in detail
admit of this collection my heart beats
higher and higher it is nothing about
part of jazz but it's a part of music
history of Germany and of asana and look
around you can find so much things a
bounty of cultural riches
those are Reinhardt Lawrence's
recommendations for a visit to eyes
enough